welcome to this video playing I'm a
beast again yeah I had this draw in the
room what do we have now greenfeld no I
try a little line here that I just a
couple of days ago I think yesterday
actually I saw an opening server in the
new in chess llego the yearbook where
this line was mentioned and there was
one idea that i found particularly
interesting maybe we see that in this
game the idea is that after a 5 d 5 9
a-6 white goes gee for 95 and then
Bishop f3 I never saw this maneuver and
I found it interesting that's an
interesting idea okay he goes c6 why not
why not interesting waiting move um yeah
just not a three probably at least he is
now committed to this kind of see six
base setup v5y I think probably three is
good those setups with the a66 b5 they
are not that bad I think they are often
underestimated um I think like blankets
probably if white plays perfectly
slightly worse but it's not that
terrible and if why it is not really an
expert can easily easily backfire I
wonder if c5 is a move but i'm not sure
about it i just want to want to do this
maybe look see one would have been
interesting
okay now I plane c5 add this I wanted to
do this earlier but with the bishop on
CA that didn't really feel very
promising now with the bishop on b7 this
is so much more interesting idea KOCO
age three I can maybe take a couple of
times and take on a four okay
okay I'm preventing naija for now he
never wanted to do it over obviously I
always thought that is an idea oh I
didn't expect this morally I thought you
would use the diagonal or the e5 square
surprising I'm trying night be three to
a five as a possible regrouping here we
go
yeah why does sorry very slightly better
here due to the space however it doesn't
look like black handsome a lot to fear
still very solid the only weakness is c6
and it's not really happening all that
quickly that I'm doing something there
okay um I guess preparing queen d 1 is
an idea interesting
i don't i know i don't know like this 95
or 95 I can do that immediately but I
like the route is six idea I'm a bit
surprised that he allowed this maybe
it's not really a big deal but still I'd
I think I wouldn't have allowed that or
does he have 94 now like tactics yeah
94 84 take one D aid
okay so I didn't didn't see that coming
a bit awkward I don't release think I've
got a problem or anything but it wasn't
necessary to allow all that that the
night comes to deform that is a good
move I was just about to play a push-up
reform okay how do I get rich get rid of
this may be fun that's maybe 92
wow really that that looks better white
like with f4 and stuff I don't believe
it really g 3 90 95 web it's got 95 hmm
ok and i take c 5 ok week we are having
some tactics again
um
it wasn't has a very nice position and I
spoiled it unfortunately time morning
and it's still not that easy it's bishop
it's rather passive maybe I still have
some practical chances here
jet understand this isn't this no good
for me I'm picking up the pawns here how
is he playing this I don't understand
let's bring this around or a g3 is got
t3 ok didn't even see that move I really
need a break here
I'm winning amazing check black forfeits
on time what was an awful game what an
awful game yay especially after having
such a nice controlled position where
white is just a little bit better I mean
it's not much but it's very comfortable
yeah probably i got tempted to do this I
should just take it and probably and and
play this position here white has a
little something because of the yeah
because of the space it's funny the
engine gives this move and why it is
clearly better which I tend to believe I
meanest pieces of very cramped but black
doesn't have to take you can play an OB
should be seven awesome but this is more
like an Academical advantage it's not
really something serious and t IM ok the
engine just wants to take everything
maybe that's better really check ya hear
it see choir that's equally always get
c5 in them and i probably should do that
around here i'm a little bit struggling
o night x e6 I didn't really think of
this at all but that's very interesting
pawns are dangerous 0.7 according to
starfish maybe nope didn't see it
yeah i thought i would get an f of g
three or four esh for head strong and
now he's got the this tactic yeah
somehow somehow I should lose but I
don't really know how exactly could have
done it and this is this honking out to
be three yeah i can i can go with the
king but i thought that this would be
good didn't really understand that what
did i do here why did not play king f3
sometimes sometimes you really wonder
yeah I can i just drop the whole temper
there yet this this might be a draw
positional draw if I just keep shuffling
I will I already overlooked I totally
overlooked that that t2 was was going to
go I'm going to happen and I mean and
that I'm winning here is kind of kind of
amazing yeah bishop I mean bishop t5
anything and no I'm I'm winning yeah
this is just a gift pure gift yeah
thanks for watching